i know so much
i really do this really speaks to me
let's serve up some news sunny side up
variety reports that the third oh and
final magic mike movie is coming to hbo
max wait a minute i know why don't do
that farewell thing to me don't why you
gotta stop making that i already got my
tickets for this one you guys are you
okay
um just keep making i don't care if you
have magic mike aarp okay i'm showing up
okay are you gonna buy tickets to this
new magic mine i like that um steven
soderbergh the amazing director who did
erin brockovich and
oh my graphic traffic and the first
magic mike
and the very first magic mic that he
collaborated with channing tatum he's
just the most talented filmmaker um so
they're gonna do it together again and
gosh i hope the whole cast shows up i'm
in yeah i just hope that cookie week
doesn't ruin my chance of getting a part
in this new magic mic movie
in style reports that mariah's got a
brand new holiday special on apple tv i
actually watched last year's it was
really fun um and she made her holiday
rounds and revealed a big relationship
deal breaker on the show if you're not
into the holidays she's not into you
yeah that makes sense yeah if you want
to ride in her sleigh you better jingle
all the way
it makes sense
did
rosie
like not date someone who wasn't super
holiday gung-ho yeah i mean i'm i'm
pretty holly jolly i'm hojo to the max i
put up my treat like as i'm chewing the
last bite of turkey on thanksgiving
anybody else do that wait
and so why that's important i think it's
because it means you're spirited
and you value that time which is all
about family and tradition and that's
important to me you i have learned that
it's about choosing your battles and
that for me isn't one of them really i
just don't care you don't love the
holidays that doesn't bother me i've got
enough spirit to go around for everybody
i guess it's true
parents magazine reports that school
photo companies are offering retouching
services on kids school photos there's
been a backlash from parents who say it
sends the wrong message to kids one mom
posted this pic the photo company had
photoshopped out her child's freckles
and then she tweeted asking to get them
back other parents say they see a place
for it and one person said their son got
scratched by their cat on his face just
days before the annual photo and they
wish they had been able to fix it brook
thoughts i don't think that it's the
right message i really don't i think
it's not fair because you're telling
you're sending the child a message that
says you're not good enough so we're
going to fix you you're something's
wrong with you we're going to fix you
and if you're starting that young god
help them by the time they're older
completely yes
i hate this for little kids i will
say like 16 17 there are a couple
pictures i wouldn't mind a little
photoshop on from my past you know what
i mean
the new york post reports apparently
they love trading baking recipes okay
tommy lee posted a video on tick tock
showing his pal john texting him one
wednesday night asking for his killer
peanut butter chocolate chip recipe
and later john shared a pic of his
cookies in the oven calling himself a
regular johnny crocker
and we're in luck because guess what
we've got some of tommy lee's special
recipes
right here oh my gosh we have the this
is the the actual peanut butter cookie
recipe and he does it with chocolate
chips in it i heard john travolta also
drinks it with lemonade
i feel like this is wrong on many levels
but i'm going to try it
before there's a little salt okay if you
want the bowl oh tommy lee
[Applause]
drew you cannot tell me that's not a
great peanut butter cookie no
it is
all right next we've got a real heart
warmer it's just one of those fun facts
that
develops into something really lovely
it's from tanks good news and it's about
a special 20-year friendship that
started by accident
it all started when gladys hankerson who
was around 60 at the time called the
wrong number
when she was trying to reach her sister
and instead she got a man in his 20s
named mike moffitt listen it was just
one of those mistakes and they got to
talking and she actually
had lost her son oh and they started a
friendship and they were talking every
few weeks for 20 years
and this thanksgiving mike now 46
surprise gladys now 80 in person and she
called it the happiest thanksgiving ever
oh
i
i know
i know so much
i really do this really speaks to me i
know can i tell you something i answer
every phone number when it's like a
number you don't know i call it phone
roulette and i'm always picking up just
because i'm hoping it's like an 80 year
old woman out there call me call me
please this is my fantasy
tonight is the fourth night of hanukkah
which i celebrate with my daughters
and um this is our pick from the little
yellow book which is my personal guide
to things that i would love for you to
know about
and
this awesome menorah wall hanging is
made by pockets of learning so i
received this and i had to share and a
big thanks to you at modern tribe for
sending this to us modern tribe has so
many fun unique jewish gifts on their
site moderntribe.com
[Music]